so recently i got a really bad cold and
spent a couple of days on the couch
watching daytime tv and old movies like
you have done
i grabbed a couple of cough drops to
suit the pain of a sore throat
long story short i wondered why cough
drops made my throat feel better
and well here we are with the video
today cough drops are just hard candy
with an extra ingredient
menthol menthol is a compound
traditionally extracted from the
peppermint plant
or more recently synthesized from either
mycerine or m-cresol
cough drops get their medicinal
properties through menthol which causes
pain relief by binding to two different
receptors in your peripheral nervous
system
in your throat one of these receptors
trpm8
causes a cool sensation associated with
menthol when menthol binds to the trpm8
receptor
it causes calcium to flow into the
calcium channels
signaling the brain to interpret a cool
sensation when you put a cough drop in
your mouth or rub a menthol-based cream
on your skin you feel a cooling
sensation
due to interaction with the trpm8
receptor
but what about the pain relief from a
sore throat well that has to do with the
kappa opioid receptor
the kappa opioid receptor is found in
the brain spinal cord and like the trpm8
receptor
and sensory neurons throughout your
entire body including in your throat
kappa opioid receptors have several
different functions
such as modulating pain consciousness
and mood with the most notable being
pain modulation when certain molecules
bind to the kappa receptor
it releases dopamine producing analgesic
effects
one notorious group of molecules that
causes a large release of dopamine when
taken
are opiates opiates such as heroin
morphine
oxycodone and others bind to the kappa
opioid receptors
inducing pain relief and euphoric
effects among the vast list of molecules
that bind to the kappa receptor
is menthol when menthol binds to kappa
receptors in your throat it induces the
analgesic effect
thereby relieving the pain for a short
period of time however
you may be asking why doesn't menthol
cause a strong pain relief effect like
heroin does
if it also binds to the same receptor
this is because menthol is a weak
agonist
an agonist is a molecule that when it
binds to a receptor
triggers that receptor's biological
response a strong agonist
binds firmly to the receptor and
therefore induces a stronger response
heroin is a very strong agonist and
binds very tightly to the kappa receptor
menthol on the other hand is a very weak
agonist and only produces
a small response this is why you have to
keep taking cough drops to feel the
effects of pain relief
and why a single dose of heroin makes
you feel euphoric
but wait there's more not all cough
drops are created equally
yeah i bet you thought they were all the
same yeah sure
companies make different cough drops for
different reasons
i'm going to use halls as an example
because i use hauls when i'm typically
sick
so i know the actual ingredients and no
this is not a paid product endorsement
so with hulls there's the traditional
kind of cough drop like the kind i
mentioned earlier in the video where the
active ingredient is menthol
specifically hall's relief cough drops
have 7.5 milligrams of menthol per cough
drop
and reduces coughing and throat pain
hence the relief label
hall soothing cough drops have less
menthol 2.5 milligrams to be exact
and act as a watered-down cough drop to
have a less harsh menthol sensation
hall's defense cough drops don't have
any menthol at all but rather 135
milligrams of vitamin c
to boost your immune system and act as a
cold preventative
finally hall's breezers also contains no
menthol but
instead has seven milligrams of pectin a
polysaccharide that coats the mucous
membranes in your throat to reduce
coughing
soreness and make breathing easier
you